donna here with the news update
according to leaked images it appears
that the next generation version of
Assassin's Creed will at least partly be
set in Paris screenshots that relate to
Kotaku shows an assassin wandering the
streets of Paris with landmarks such as
natural dam on the Seine River being
visible and all you guys say day in
willits the game is rumored to be set in
the French Revolution era featuring a
new assassin to the series named are no
according to the report this Assassin's
Creed his codename unity and his plan
for next gen only so Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 while a completely
different Assassin's Creed game referred
to as comet is coming out on the xbox
360 and playstation 3 it is currently
unknown if one or both of these titles
is to be released on the pc the
screenshots also show buttons maps to
parkour up and parkour down which is
said to be a new mechanic presumably
introduced in the release of the next
game in the series rumors of a French
revolutionary ass creed game have been
rife ever since before the release of AC
3 so do these screenshots finally
confirm the wishes of gamers all around
the world for updates on this news story
and more stay tuned to gamespot com